i look into the crowd and i see every
single person in there
is going through something i could like
say i like it like
that i like it and
i have the same problem billy eilish is
taking fans behind the music
and inside her phenomenal rise to
stardom
i'm so excited the 19 year old singer
dropped
this trailer on her youtube channel
tuesday for
billy eilish the world's a little blurry
on apple tv plus
and it looks like it's going to be very
personal
i honestly don't know how any artist of
any age
is doing it without a parent
the movie will offer an intimate look at
the making of billy's debut album
when we all fall asleep where do we go
and how she's navigated her fame
and success it is a horrible time to be
a teenager
[Music]
kids are depressed in addition the
trailer showcases how billy has used her
platform to be an advocate for mental
health awareness
that's all i'd say to be honest with you
the grammy winner has been very
open about her struggles with tourette
syndrome body dysmorphia
and depression i look into the crowd and
i see
every single person in there is going
through something
i could like say i like it like that i
like it
[Music]
and i have the same problem
i was like why don't i turn this into
art instead of
just living with it hey you guys need to
be okay
because y'all are the reason i'm okay
okay in the march issue of vanity fair
billy said the documentary will also
reveal details about a romantic
relationship she's never
publicly spoken about telling the
magazine quote
that was a huge part of my life adding
and nobody knew it it was this main
thing that was taking control of my life
we made this album in a bedroom at our
house that we grew up in
so it's really like anything is possible
the trailer features
several moments of billy's collaboration
with her brother phineas
making what we all fall asleep where do
we go was like the most exhausting
tiring excruciating thing she opened up
to et in 2019 about working together for
her debut
album we had a deadline and sometimes
it's really good to have deadlines and
it helped us you know because we were
like
doing everything that we had to do but
also it was kind of miserable because it
was like work work work work
not really like enjoyable because we had
to finish it you know
and we were so stuck and eventually we
got it it was like the most satisfying
thing